it's time for roses and roses a bit
chilly how did that feel was it ah I was
gonna nervous and we want to show off
your beautiful pants oh these are from
your line backer chilly line available
at Macy's weird it's a high-waisted
moment it is a high wish I love I feel
like these pants make my waist look
skinnier than any other pants I own I
need these okay Becca Julie thank you
for being here to play roses and Rose a
sip or spill this is a game where as you
called it a bit of a twist on its truth
or drink you can either answer the
question spill or take a drink
sip so let's get you some Rose day all
right are you a big girl a girl I love
yeah okay great um here's my question
when I spill yeah do I have to elaborate
on my answer I would prefer the
elaboration but let's go on a journey as
they say yes girl I have lipstick oh my
gosh I started doing it before you go
through don't even pour me a glass at my
drinking that's like let's let me get
ready all right so we've got a variety
of questions for you here today babe we
got some questions about your life some
bachelor nation stuff let's get to it
first of all bachelor nation questions
we'll start off in the past and move to
the filter right okay I don't even think
people realize I was on The Bachelor and
okay guide people yeah I did twice I
know but people don't remember me from
Christmas season they only remember me
mostly from Benz I feel like interesting
oh and I got further on Christmas season
people come up to more for that season
yeah okay one of our questions sipper
spill who were you more into Chris or
Ben I was more into Ben simply because I
went back on the show yeah because I
wanted to date him you know I was kind
of like oh this is a co opportunity
let's see what happens and I liked him
but it took a little longer to get there
was I kind of already liked Ben yeah
going into it but by the way every time
you answer I have to drink
oh oh this I played the game with yeah
it's a win-win for everybody yeah what
is your biggest pet peeve about fellow
bachelor nation alumni something that it
annoys you that people do this or act
like this say this thing I think
probably the thing that I notice the
most is the idea that the level of
celebrity that I think some have after
the show which I will say things have
taken a turn since my season and I do
think the more recent seasons they are
kind of what your celeb they're dating
celebrities supermodels so maybe more
from like my seasons do you mean people
having that celebrity you know more than
ego do you got to be Monica okay yeah
got it cuz like really we all just were
like lucky to be chosen to be on this
show is like we got lucky
really we didn't do anything that
life-changing so who has the biggest ego
I don't know but I'm gonna drink I'm not
it's not any one specific I knew that
was coming
okay that wasn't even on your card you
look like added Batgirl to follow up
did you ever go on a first date with
someone in bachelor nation but not want
to go on a second and if so who no no I
didn't I haven't dated a ton within the
bachelor nation okay
there's no there's not been any
relationships we don't know about
anything you want to reveal oh this did
happen we did go out a couple times
no I kissed people but like no I didn't
go on date yes I said this IV I've
kissed people could you give me one
I kissed Dean at one point but it was
very it was a it was a very drunken kiss
both of us and it was not a romantic
situation at all
how was he as a kisser I don't remember
was it ugly horrible
was it at stagecoach oh no I think I
haven't had any bachelor nation hookups
at stage go okay great okay all right
you'll left behind in that
any other bachelor nation questions here
in our game anybody who turned down for
a date somebody asked you out and you
said I turned Eric bigger asked me out
but I was in a relationship so I just
told him I was very flattered but I am
was currently in a relationship and
couldn't go on a date she's really
answering the questions guys I'm sure
though I'm sure the tables are whole
turn have you ever met anyone on
bachelor nation who had really bad
breath actually no okay
minty fresh people hey no I gotta get
out they have like Listerine strips for
everybody everyone to wear yeah how
could happen at any moment yeah who is
the biggest diva in bachelor nation
right now biggest diva well let's move
into then personal questions about you
okay this is where I'll follow you um
what is the last thing you googled
should I look I didn't remember no but I
have my phone okay look yeah sure maybe
it's weird I know how do you keep me
answering these questions I'm gonna
drink for all year I'm gonna do a little
catch-up drink for your answers oh my
gosh I googled I've got health insurance
this is a big morning for me actually
you didn't have health and sure enough I
have to tell you the funniest thing I
currently do that I had so much anxiety
about not having it with all the
traveling and stuff I do I'm like of all
people okay so you got it I got it
cheers you're hella transracial I'm
gonna drink to that adult thing mm-hmm
she's got her own line at Macy's but
don't let her trip
[Music]
Wow very good we took care of the
situation
speaking of your clothing line who would
be a dream celebrity you'd like to see
wearing your clothing line I mean and or
has anybody reached out to you and
you're like oh my god I can't believe
that person is a fan of mine none of
that yet
I would say zendaya or Jennifer Aniston
which I saw that you interviewed her and
I just
Rachel was great yeah she's great she's
really lovely yeah cheers to Frankie
yeah cuz I'm gonna ask you about your
relationship okay okay so you're in a
relationship okay you have confirmed
this I've heard you talk about this oh
yeah degrees okay but you don't want to
share much right why is that because
it's it's something that's mine and I
feel like I'm pretty open about
everything else in my life my health
insurance status and you know honestly
like I share pretty much everything but
it was just my last relationship with
Robert was very public and it made it
very hard once we broke up just the
pressure of it and I decided with this
one that I didn't want that so I just
have kept it private you know mm-hmm
until I don't want to anymore
well that was gonna need my second
question will there be a point and what
would it take for you to say I do want
to go public with us I honestly don't
know because the people who like I want
to know know about it you know and are
involved in my life
and and I think it's there's something
really special that it's just ours you
know and it's not I've someone said a
quote the other day and they were saying
something along the lines of what people
don't know they can't ruin and there's
so many opinions and people have so much
to say about everything and I just
didn't want to let that into my
relationship it's hard you know having a
podcast and where my co-host Tonya is so
open about her life and her dating life
and then people being curious about mine
since they do follow me from my journey
to find love
it's hard in that sense to feel like oh
no am I like letting people down and I'm
not sharing about it okay I'm gonna
drink a lot because you just a guzzle
that's called friendship
wow that was I felt respect right then
okay now I'm gonna rapid-fire at you and
maybe get you to catch up with me a
little bit so you could just answer not
okay how long have you guys been dating
over a year are you in love yes there's
not much wine left well that's great
you're in love I'm freakin glad you're
in love thank you so you're happy now
I'm really happy rapid fire just like
wraps fire oh there's plenty of wine
laughs what are you talking about
Jennifer I was trying to figure out it's
so great to be happy gotta tell ya not
always a happy Left story for the
bachelor nation focus so what's
happening on this couch is working well
is this person famous maybe okay you
have to jerk it up do you talk about
marriage with this person no I'm not I'm
I'm like I barely plan my week in
advance so yeah like I'm not I just got
health insurance all right thank you for
answering I'm feeling my Rosie happiness
right now all right our last set of
questions takes you way back we're just
talking about bachelor nation again way
back to the film in days one thing you
wish you could take back or do
differently from any of your times on
the show I feel like I wouldn't wish I
would have been a little more like not
as
scared on Christmas season in the sense
of I was so nervous of how I could be
edited because I'm kind of sarcastic and
like have a dry sense of humor but I was
so nervous to go too far all not that I
came across looking like the villain you
know so I was like a Macross very timid
on that season which was fine I mean
worse things have happened but other
than that I don't really have any I
think everything kind of worked out will
we ever see you back on television
screens just in any capacity yeah I mean
yeah if it was the right show or
opportunity I guess I kind of want to
see you and Joe Joe Joe something I
would love to do something I always
talked about that what would it be
we talked about it but what like it's
kind of she has so much going on I'm
like when do you actually have time to
like go fill in too much TV show with me
because you have like three with Jordan
and then or two and she in the throws of
wedding-planning right yeah she's
waiting pointing they're building a
house
Oh casual yeah nothing nothing going on
so we're just we've talked about doing
like even if it's just like a fun little
like talk show or something but I don't
know yeah I just I would like to have
her in LA more so any excuse that we
could hang out more are we I would
imagine I mean I don't know is this
awkward are you gonna be a bridesmaid
are you gonna be the maid of honor I
don't know if that's the decided I've um
she's done interviews where she said
that I will be a bride okay if I haven't
gotten an official you're waiting for
the official action I told her I'm like
listen that's not gonna do it for me I
need an official delivery was the most
bachelor nation thing ever that
something's been revealed an interview
that the person had weirdly I saw it on
we were doing an interview together and
an event and they said something along
the lines I know you said Becca will be
a bridesmaid I was like like what I
didn't say that yeah um is she really
far into it and are you helping at all I
haven't gotten to the point
she is yeah they're I mean they're
planning it she came out she found a
dress
we went wedding-dress shopping they have
a location and I think an official date
says okay so it's I think I mean I know
there's a lot of details beyond that but
happening it's really interesting for um
for me to hear you say you wish like
you've been more yourself on Christmas
season you look back at you on Christmas
season how much do you feel like you've
changed since that time
a lot yeah I feel like I've just I think
I've gotten a lot more confident and I
think I've mean just like any any growth
like as you get older and you look back
you're like a lot of changed a lot but I
would say I think a lot of Who I am is
still the same
but I do my clothing choices have
changed I watch back and I'm like I
remember thinking that was the best
outfit ever
yeah well it's also they've upped the
ante so much now I feel like everyone
goes on to the show already having deals
they've gotten free clothes from
different brands and yeah it's different
but you know what you have your own
clothing line now I do what do you want
to do next
um you know I I love doing the podcast
and I feel like oh by the way you just
won and you know we've been very
congratulation to you it's really been
something that I think both Tony and I
are very proud of like what we've
created and not just the podcast with
the community of women and you know the
few men here and there but it's very
it's a very positive space and my hope
that we keep growing that and maybe
we're doing like a couple of live shows
and hopefully taking that further than
than just the first two that we have
kind of been the goal for next year and
maybe doing something in TV and creating
a beauty product and then the works of
doing her hair for her
you amazing hair my hair so frizzy from
the rain right now but it rains in LA
rude we're not used to it we're not
ready for it all right back it's hilly
cheers to you thanks for being here
thanks for drinking so much okay cool
this has been roses and roses a sip or
fill with Becca Tilly followed back on
Instagram check out her clothing line at
Macy's and listen to her amazing podcast
scrubbing in thank you so much for being
here
thanks for having me okay great
[Music]